مصدر العسكري اسرائيلي ان خطه بلاده لجنه
هجوم مستقلا على منشات ايران نوويه ليست
جاهزه بعد ولكن قد يتغير الوضع في حال
استقبل الجيش اوامره من المستوى السياسي
لذا اضاف المسؤول العسكري ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي سيواصل التجهيز لضربه عسكريه
الايران عبر شراء مقاتلات وذخائر خاصه ثم
ذكر ذكر باهميه الغارات الاسرائيليه على
سوريا ودورها في تعطيل موضوع ايران
العسكري حسبته اما في اوكرانيا فحذر
المصدر العسكري ان اسرائيل ترصد اداء
ايران بتفعيل المسيرات في اوكرانيا ولديها
حلول لمواجهه هذه القدرات وفي جزء اخر من
هذه التصريحات المسربه علق المسؤول
والاستخبارات الاسرائيليه على الوضع في
الضفه الغربيه محذرا من تصعيد محتمل